girl good morning gamers it's another
beautiful day oh my gosh it's actually
night in Minecraft we have dark year
again and everything is great everything
is fantastic couple changes couple
changes let me show you in here as you
can tell I haven't fixed I haven't fixed
the door yet I'm working on it
tell okay they're sleeping hello so this
is how you sleep just standing on top of
other people oh look at him
this is how you guys sleep just looking
up they just couldn't animate their eyes
getting closed oh yeah Brad is back
that's right he's not editing anymore I
don't know where you came from you've
been gone for like ten episodes actually
let me let me go to sleep as well oh my
gosh is that a cat all these people just
appear on an arm's quiet kitty I have a
cat for you let me just make a couple
beds because they keep freaking I didn't
ask for this let it be clear i okay I
did ask for a law frickin but not so
many freaking where is the kitty
freaking sound his hand hello
come down kitty oh my god it's kind of
cute no oh no you die now what they fell
on say feet oh maybe there's two cats
okay okay okay oh this one is cuter I
like this one more hello eat love me you
ate the thing oh my gosh I'll do more
fishing later I guess I don't need to
kidnap people if their kids decide to
stay here as well right so this guy's
trades infinity which you guys told me
it's actually pretty good and if I don't
trade with them I can just take this out
and replace it and it should actually
change somehow their profession again
but only if I haven't traded
so let's let's try and do that see what
happened this has now became a library
this is the weird what happened to this
alright does that mean you change the
looting one no feather falling okay so
that one changed silic touch okay that's
pretty good but what we are looking for
is mending so let's just keep bad
changing I didn't realize it would be
that fast they just go up to it and wait
punch I like to punch Oh what do i
enchant that gets punch haha
DJ cow I think that's probably more I
think this is a probably a better night
name than what I what I used to give him
in the mid well let me show you spend
what I got if you put infinity on your
bow now as you can see I have 27 arrows
and I shoot an arrow at the tower of
whether she still got 27 arrows I have
infinite arrows how did I not know that
was the thing
alright Sven we're going let's go spend
we have stuff to do today come on wow
you are very slow wait is that another
cat ah I forgot my fishing rod
give me that Teddy stuff I love this
area now it's so cozy
Sven likes it too he's just struggling a
little bit just a tiny bit he's a little
bit slow it's fine we are all we've
already we've we've all apparently you
guys told me that you have to let these
guys out because they need to go and
frik somewhere else damn look at these
boys I got so many shoots from them damn
alright alright I'll let you go I'll let
you go yeah oh sorry
you've done your peppers you've done
their purpose you can go now where is
spended he's swimming look at it he's
swimming absolute brain light alright
fine
I just need to go - lets go - Felix oh I
just I just really gotta make it okay
give me fish for once I want they should
know treasures right virgin toad so
today's episode is as you may have
guessed water oh look they're escaping
water really related we have a conduit
which we can use to build an underwater
base and we for our quest to kill up on
breaking 3 all right you're almost
satisfied you're almost there we can
build an underwater house and we are on
the quest to kill the width or one of
the bosses in Minecraft and to prepare
we need to try it which will drop from
one of the water people first I want to
cat though all right let me see here
what Oh looks like it caught the big one
whoop bet it really did stop get out
so apparently cats are really good in
Minecraft because they can scare away
creepers which sounds like a good thing
to have at your base to be honest and
that mushroom to go straight from the
titty a stick what all right get out get
out
all right Sven let's get out of here I
know do you don't like the kitty cats
neither do i but they're helpful okay
I'm really good with cats guys where do
you go hello cat hello Nicolai locally
there Scott are you guys just sleep all
day and do nothing
is that what you do you just sleep all
day do why are they always more of you
as well where's the cakes why are there
another one sighs it's here I must ask
Council of sheep for guidance
Oh council of sheep
give me guidance of what to do I should
dig down find diamonds deep below spank
blue sheeps but no I'm not gonna do that
weird very well
big I shall dig straight what not near
there second what there's like a secret
chain here
Wow whoa what the Sheep built this cave
what that's so crazy I wonder where this
goes
whoa the ball of ah oh it's an ambush
whoa I made it out alive thank gosh okay
Wow
diamonds what their sheep thank you
listen there's one thing everyone in the
planet can agree on is mining diamonds
look freaking sweet okay so I saved it
for the episodes and we got five are you
kidding me come on are you kidding me
are you kidding me you're letting me
down man fortune three let me down if
this continues I'll have to put a down
payment on my house I almost forgot the
most important part we have the turtle
helmet now which will make any water
related activity a lot more epic okay so
now it's time for you and me classic
adventure
let's go gamer I put the boat on the
wrong side of the tracks I am a genius I
know thank you
so yeah just a couple boys Sven has a
shield what is happening
why do I have a what this is my texture
pack that's awesome
what that's so cool
oh we found one we found one he's
shooting at Sven is perfect drop your
Triton now or there will be consequences
now or consequence he dropped it right
away
yes when we rule the school of where's
the boatsman
ah watch out for that sweat watch out
for that said yes right keep your nose
up you're fine you're fine I'm not
panicking I'm not panicking where they
both go there's another mushroom biome
now wait we've been there before I'm
starting to think I'm the luckiest
unlucky person in Minecraft because all
the drops are just insane but all my
loved ones are gone
come here Smith you're the only one left
again I lose you again a bear to be
without you that's right same foot same
pose Papa gotta go
floppy snappy all right look how fast I
can mine underwater now because I have
the helper okay garbage but then can eat
so it's okay and there's another one
unbreaking 3 I guess I can take that so
many of you were like oh you have a
trident Felix it's in your it's in your
summerhouse no I lost it okay I lost it
from another one okay I'll run oh don't
you dare him
are you okay eight they freaking destroy
your boat do they're crazy they're
dangerous
I lost it from one of the water temple
and look there is one literally right
outside our spawn and I feel like we
should we should take over it not just
beat the bosses not just pee pee poo poo
I mean full-on take over it claim it as
ours put a conduit in there make it nice
and cozy put a little fire honestly
considering how many pet
I've lost the fact that Simone is alive
is nothing but a miracle
Hey look Phoebe poopy is doing great
there's still so many places I haven't
even discovered him mine crime I haven't
been to the snow areas I haven't found a
coral leaf reef weeds just getting
started fam there's so many more people
I wanna kidnap this is a dangerous place
man I'm not gonna lie if you had a scuba
diving suit I wouldn't hesitate to bring
it because I know how powerful you are
underwater underwater
Sven is like a freakin savage but I need
you to hold down the fort for me buddy
okay so where do we build the condo then
stop I say we build it underneath right
did I not bring any doors I went all
this way and I didn't bring any doors
I'm an absolute maniac got to make sure
I don't do this wrong then oh god this
is really bad
Oh God Oh God
I need teddy milk fast hey you are hey
you teddy more more teddy
thanks you know what they say if you
ain't got doors just make them that's
the expression no one brought a door
through the party we'll just make your
own fan that's the expression
hey forgot to make your doors just go to
the woods cut them down and make them
yourself that's the expression right
Sven oh yeah that's right all right BAM
we have door the door situation is all
right we got to make sure this condom
it's activated oh my god this oh god
it's happening again I remember why I
don't like this place this is a bad
place and I wish I had a baby right now
there's a bad place and I wish I had a
baby I'm going back to get my baby what
are you looking at
I keep killing them but there's just
more and more and more and more and more
and it's so stressful
this is more all the time let me set up
my conduit that's all I ask
and to drink my titty juicy piece I said
all right I need to dig that yeah I want
to set up the conduit
I have doors on my side
what are you sponges okay if I said it
went great I would be lying not gonna
line oh here's the one of the bosses oh
it's my super bowl
I haven't finish this arrow still do the
same amount of damage No
yes to to go baby say oh that craziest
thing that's a look - down there
dang it's so hard to find the last one
oh my god he's right there okay you're
about to taste a knuckle sandwich so you
do the same damage the error just
doesn't fly as far look at his little
tail your loser I can't believe this is
an actual strategy I'm using come on
yeah Oh things are about to be a little
different around here from now on this
town is called puta pack town and
nothing else all year all right so now
what we can do is we can drink the milk
the titty and there will be no more
debuff that makes us so I can't mine and
stuff which means we can take these back
down oh my god infinity is the best so
yeah time to clear up the space BAM
water be gone fan don't want to see your
face sayonara
Aquos on first the water flowing from I
don't know why this is so oddly
satisfying to do it's like
weird ASMR ah oh that was good yeah
Oh it's sinking by finally I can bring
Sven back in here oh my gosh I did it
yeah first room that feels good dude
now we can peacefully get the gold for a
year again now I can just tell people I
built this place and no one will know I
watched watch this oh oh are you guys in
here oh sorry what's this what you guys
home I think I'm just gonna spend some
time playing this out I'll let you guys
know when it's finished
so yeah this took me about an hour to
clear out then I finally plays down the
conduit so that's cool
then I decided to big a tunnel back to
my spawn then I realized that tunnel was
in the wrong direction when I finished
up the the right tunnel and that's where
we're back baby okay so three hours
later no it didn't take that long we are
back and it's time for me to do
something actually there's something I
want to do first wow what a nice village
is it only you left getting boat there's
no escape get in the boat just do it
it's the only way Oh God
got him caught another one spin yeah
stop moaning look Jurgen caught another
one there's a wall and I can't go in
there just wait your mind about to be
blown that's right this is your home now
they're all sleeping that's so cute
let's be careful not to wake them up
wake up battle stations
that's right gather here this is what I
wanted
trade me good stuff I said good stuff
knock back get out of here impaling
that's what I have when your mom knocked
back that's what your mom do when I am
your mom
okay so then it's time for me to show
you something Austin follow me buddy
there's gonna be cool hey Sven remember
in like Episode nine when you were
caught underneath water and we were all
so scared well now we rule the water
baby
that's right Sven look at this so
awesome so but yeah I got the whole
thing completely dried it's so dope I
also have the conduit as well so even if
I go into water full night vision full
breathing does that work for Sven as
well that'd be so cool get the out of
house yeah get him Sven
yeah I guess ready yeah yeah freak him
up incredible job you can get him spend
you can get him
you did it spend good job
so yeah just to show you guys the whole
stay the whole thing baby it's so
satisfying to use the sponges why did I
do this because I can that's why now I
was saying like a lot of people do this
and then they keep this as their main
hub I don't think that's what I want to
do I just wanted to see for me it was
like a bucket list try not to get lost
in it could be dangerous all right well
we should head back because we have some
other stuff to do but yeah the conduit
is in here it is tempting if I should
get it back actually yeah look at that
yeah we rule the oceans thing I am
Poseidon the Poseidon has the Trident
right the god of the Greek mythology god
of the ocean apparently it was going to
be decided between Hades who's the god
of the underworld between hit cuz
they're Poseidon Hades are brothers and
when it was decided between them who was
gonna rule the underworld and who's
gonna rule the ocean they were always in
such competition with each other that
when he was announced that Poseidon got
to rule the ocean he just went yeah
Frick yeah even though that's not
necessarily what he wanted he just
wanted to shove it in Hades face and
Hades did the exact same thing beyond
the world yes that's awesome that's what
they want to rule some random Greek
mythology in the PD pilots minecraft
letsplay why what would you guys prefer
to rule the underworld or the ocean I'd
pick the ocean so yeah I built this
thing here because I thought it could be
cool to build a track in between the
houses coming from Ikea tower god the
game likes whenever I come here I think
it's time to fight the weather soon so
it's like please there's something about
baby we're back gamers so it's about
dang times that I enchant my try to do I
have it channeling yeah it is blunt so
yeah this will give it channeling
the enchantment which means that once
there's a thunderstorm
once I if I hit the pigs that will be
turning to pig soldiers which we're
gonna use to fight the weather so now we
just have to wait for a thunderstorm
basically obviously we don't know when
it's gonna be thunder so it could be
days it could be years it could be
tonight who knows trade me good stuff
pick a job you pleb I just realize since
we have the sponges we could literally
dry out this in ocean what I do want to
do actually is I want to maybe place the
conduit here that is definitely not
right and we got to add it here and now
we can just chill at the bottom of the
ocean for no reason whatsoever what the
Sheep would be so proud of me
hey look here's the chest thing one of
the first thing I found I can appreciate
what a meatball from the ocean now look
I'm just like you damn he raped though
damn turtle beer if does break down whoa
no one talks about that whoa are you
serious how was this in my map does it
go to this surface whoa
so cool look how dark it is without the
water this is how it actually looks like
I keep putting down torches I know my
man just digging gold underwater that's
whatever so yeah for no reason at all
this is my house
underwater house
can I sleep oh my god I can good night
gamers what a great sleep I mean bloob
bloob bloob maybe I'll build something
that starts from the bottom and goes to
the top that might be cool look Brad
inside this here alright let's see if
they finally have decided to be useful
silic touch that's that's what I have
with your mama okay I think for this
little town to work out we need to
expand just a bit yes go in there yes
things are I get about to get the little
stricter around here get in the back no
packet it do your job your job and stop
complaining you could be anything if you
put your mind to it look this guy became
a bed yes yes don't talk to each other
stop talking another one bites the dust
I don't pay you guys to talk to each
other say I got the trap doors just so I
can
okay Sven welcome to what their sheeps
lovemaking central first of all here's
our our village look he became amazing
now so I can change the trade of these
just by placing a work block in front of
them hopefully in a second same with
this one I just removed it and he just
became a normal one so I want to
obviously expand this so I can trade
with a bunch of different villagers so
we have I introduce to you Sven don't
worry it's double-sided glass so they
can't see us you can looks and it's a
lot it's miracle of life when he doesn't
one is that gun to you and too young for
this
it's okay they can't see through the
glass this is the freaking shape no you
don't belong in freakin chamber get out
how do you even get in friend get out of
freaking chamber right now so for them
to freak they need to think that there's
beds around them like extra beds and I
think trapdoor makes it so that they
can't go but they think they can go I
think that's hot
don't look at me like that all right
sorry I'm not here I'm not here I'm not
here not here not here don't worry no
one sees you so they need to eat 12
potatoes - Frick so we're just gonna
they don't see me they don't see me they
don't see me make sure he eats all of
them make sure the other guy eats all
the parts eat the potatoes the potatoes
and do whatever they can't see me
because I'm behind the glass oh okay
okay and now they should be able to
frickin spend
just don't weigh villager freaking is
like milk it only happens to win that
you're not looking no wait that's not
the expression all right so you changed
your blast protection so it is working
he's a farmer
how ah I have to actually go back to the
flower place one second okay we're back
here because I need a couple more pink
ones it's a very strange episode Cottam
[Applause]
have they fricked yet come on guys do
they need another bed man
yes another one yeah get him Sven Oh No
sit sit don't hurt them then stop they
were put Spanish murdering spend his
roof let's stop it see 10 see see he's
sweating you're crazy
stop stop stop stop Sven I need them
spend you absolute savage don't look at
me like that you know full well what you
did oh don't tell me I let's also not
forget the gold for our number one boy
our golden boy
isn't that right spin so if you guys
remember in the jungle we had this
really weird area with flowers
everywhere which is just what I need for
a little something-something they're
gonna love this he loved picking flowers
more than any Swedish man picks up
flowers lo lo look look
god damn so many flowers it's raining
please be Thunder a pirate ship on top
of on top of the water I'll take it
Thanks
Oh perfect I need trapdoors I'll show
you what I'm doing in a second right now
I just need resources whoa a third
treasure Dan all right what rich I got
too many flowers what do I throw away
now that I found a treasure map I have
to find it obviously suffering from
success and we find another one and
suffering oh my god come on what their
sheep make it thunder iceberg what is
that
said Jesus on the cross in Minecraft why
whoa wow I've never seen snow in
Minecraft so pretty
[Music]
this is so cool if only spendin uragan
conceived I went to pick flowers and it
got all crazy
they should be here somewhere in this
piece of sand
all right we'd be digging oh yeah
bit easier than it used to be there it
is so easy yes
come on Thunder what does she please I
think it's a day later and at last at
long last you decided to trade me
mending yes hold on let me get my purse
your again I have mending oh my god the
cat finally mending or cat get the fish
all they're all cooked the salmon needs
to be raw yes
I can't wine get out of my way Turtles I
need to fish fast why
this is taking too long I'm going in
Swedish style get in the bucket yes
now we put you on land and they would
chop you up that's how you fish in
Sweden kit please be dammit next time
don't blow this oh my kid work right
away yes yes and even right next to
mending baby
let's give elaborate at this yes
and then this Loretta it's pouring hula
Britta purring
all right gamers this episode has gone
on well enough oh I did everything I
wanted to I'm so happy
isn't that right hola PITA Lula Britta
meet Sven thank you guys for watching
another episode smash like if you
enjoyed check out the merch I really
really appreciate it thank you will we
defeat the wither next episode will I
get the enchantment for my Trident watch
next episode to find hat thanks for
watching guys bye bye